pour parler des plans dead absolument
exceptionnel on retrouve clément gignac
qui économiste en chef et vice président
principal à l'industrielle-alliance
bonsoir clément gignac
bonsoir alors une aide directe aux
citoyens c'est assez simple quand même
2002 la par mois est ce que c'était
vraiment la bonne solution
oui c'était la meilleure solution parce
qu'on va pas se permettre de se ramasser
15 avril de técou s'apercevoir qu'il ya
des problèmes
les ordinateurs de tels initiales
d'assurance emploi avec le message aux
revenus tant que pense que des assassins
ça va tacler j'ai aussitôt qu'ils ont
mis sans solde ou qui tout à coup en
plus de contrats entrepreneurs peu
importe qui compte qu'un vide comme un
numéro d'assurance sociale est déjà en y
imprimant sa du revenu
son nom il va recevoir des mails dollars
soit imposable mais entre nous j'ai râlé
- nos données chanceux on n'a pas
vraiment pesé sur mejia des sabots de
suite à ceux qui n'ont besoin
le chèque ans de suite et même si que
vous allez avoir l'assurance emploi pour
un employé vous inscrivez de suite à
cela et si vous l'avez poids doit
l'assurance-emploi ben c'est encore
mieux
hello ce qui est intéressant gerald
c'est que on sait que ces 2000 par mois
pour les quatre prochains mois -73
financier gamin mois gérard j'ai
travaillé à ta voix vous savez le en
2008 2009 serait dit moustapha lô je
suis étonné agréablement surpris fier
d'être canadien parce que là on dégager
vite là que ça s'est vraiment bien
en même temps les gens qui ont perdu des
revenus des contrats et leur emploi
trouve que ça prend du temps en même
temps parce que le portail va être cessa
avril et les revenus vont venir a pas
que dans les dix jours suivant vous avez
vous avez sûrement des liens avec une
caisse une banque la caisse et la banque
ac lors que vous allez avoir de mille
piastres et ils vont faire preuve de
souplesse y aussi le don que je pense
qu'il faut faire preuve au gros bon
c'est le à quelque part les allées des
moyens de vous repérer par le puits
personne qui sait quelqu'un paie pas son
hypothèque ou super passe après sa carte
de crédit l'oeil parce qu'il reproduit
ci le dans les trois prochains mois qui
vont se présenter chez vous le peu que
je pense qu'on bouge dans le bon sens
être humain ce qui en font assez remet
un que sais je signe
je vais dire aux jo quand valeur 150 200
milliards selon moi les jeux ans tu as
ambiance ce soir il va voir doter terre
sur toutes les petites entreprises des
entrepreneurs parce que le 6 % de masse
salariale le plafond de 25 mille parfois
ce soit selon moi aussi mes
recommandations faut que ce soit revu à
la hausse si on marche excusez
l'expression anglaise ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis pourrait en faire plus
parce que eux notre belle équipe et
menacerait 200 milliards de dollars 2
milliards en ce moment quand on parle de
100 ou 200 7 milliards il ya 52
milliards d'êtres dirais qu'il ya 55
milliards en liquidités dans l'économie
c'est-à-dire des reports le report au
1er septembre
donc ça fait à peu près 5% du pib soit
clément gignac
exactement donc il ya une passion comme
l'annoncent d'aujourd'hui faire passer
l'effort budgétaire de 30 milliards à 50
milliards mais les liquidités non 55
personnes économies aux etats-unis
l'annoncé avec 10% de leur économie
évidemment c'est ponctuel 20 20 c'est
pas des déficits annuels récurrents mais
on voit là que vraiment davantage pour
venir un paquet de petites entreprises
qui eux au repos les moyens de continuer
nécessairement très longtemps non plus
et il faut s'entendre sur une date de
reprise des activités pour mettre le 12
avril si trop optimiste d'abord monsieur
tron moi je m'attends plus que ce soit
1er mai ou au 1er juin et une en
washington pas te voir que tout le monde
repart en même temps à cause des mythes
et change de position juste une
précision on additionne pas l'assurance
emploi plus la prestation d'urgence et
le nous c'est leur train non non c'est
que si vous avez si vous êtes un employé
vous allez avoir doivent être la chance
emploi mais vain que vous receviez votre
chèque ça peut prendre du temps
et l'idée à suivante c'est que vous avez
droit à les toucher mais mon coin ça va
être imposables puis l'on voir faire le
calcul
quelque part oui l'assurance emploi mais
s'ils avaient vraiment besoin de
liquidités inscrivez-vous suite employés
ou ou au travail autonome pour avoir les
deux mains
j'allais la voir dans les jours qui
suivent votre inscription
l'on parle qu'on est souvent chez des
amis à 200 c
terrien qui existe depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale hypo conçu pour avoir 8
millions de travailleurs qui
s'inscrivent d'une plaie et du
traitement manuel de danse donc ça
risque de dérapage est vrai pas de
chance qu'on choisit là-dessus mais je
veux juste que les gens comprennent que
si vous avez droit à 2000 dollars
d'assurance emploi par mois de ne pas
avoir deux mille dollars d'assurance
emploi puis 2000 $ de la prestation
d'urgence
non c'est ça lorsque ces clichés c'est
comme en hiver une compensation mais au
moins que tu caches qui rentrent 2200
milliards de dollars a dit le président
crom qui a dix minutes pour le plan de
match aux états-unis l'allemagne
aujourd'hui 1100 milliards d'euros ses
1700 milliards de dollars canadiens
comment clément gignac on va se sortir
de cette incroyable soutien qui devient
incroyable l'endettement phénoménal qui
va se créer mais prenez en main le grand
bain joue son rôle pour éviter la crise
des années 30 ont tiré leçon il faut que
les grandes manches substitut c'est un
privé quand il ya une situation comme ça
s'est passé c'est pas comme 2008 2010
sous secteur bancaire s'était effondré
il fut reconstruit
les actions financières fonctionne bien
donc là on s'avance temporaire mais oui
sur le coup ça fait un endettement
mais quand l'économie repart c'est pas
des déficits récurrents est dans le camp
du canadien chanceux on est obligé cette
triple all et moins qu'en 2010 on peut
se perdre
mais là on va pas faire comme en 2009 et
faire la pression parce qu'aujourd'hui
je voyais que le fmi demandé aux pays
créditeurs des pays d'afrique d'alléger
les mesures sur la dette
on va pas faire de l'austérité dans les
années suivantes comme on le fait en
2008-2009
non c'est qu'il y des la suivante il va
avoir des mesures temporaires
ok donc des mesures non récurrentes la
ce moment là mais on retourne le repos
les allées restriction budgétaire qui va
avoir des mesures qui ne seront pas
reconduits le fait que son port est
conduite au moins on revient mais à date
depuis 2010 gérard c'est tout le fardeau
était sur les banques centrales qui paie
ses taux d'intérêt le ca donne rien il
faut que tu aies que reese au niveau de
l'emploi dont repartent la machine et
donc les taux d'intérêts ça marche plus
il faut y aller autre m'a fait clément
gignac
c'est toujours intéressant est clair et
précis merci aux plaisait